>> POTATOES.
THESE STARCHY DELIGHTS HAVE
BEEN THE STAPLE OF OUR FOOD
SINCE THE DAWN OF MAN, BUT NOW
SCIENCE IS TRYING TO CHANGE ALL
THAT.
>> THE U.S. DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE HAS GIVEN THE GREEN
LIGHT TO A GENETICALLY MODIFIED
POTATO.
>> NO, POTATO!
WHY?
AND THIS DEADLY G.M.O. TUBER,
DEVELOPED BY EVIL AGRICULTURE
CORPORATIONS HAS MEN LIKE
JEFFREY SMITH TERRIFIED.
>> WE BELIEVE THAT GENETICALLY
ENGINEERED CROPS MAY BE ONE OF
THE MOST DANGEROUS INTRODUCTIONS
OF AN ADDITIVE IN SUPPLY IN OUR
HISTORY.
>> SMITH, FOUNDER OF THE
INSTITUTE FOR RESPONSIBLE
TECHNOLOGY AND ONE OF THE
LEADING ANTI-G.M.O. VOICES IN
THE WORLD, EXPLAINS EXACTLY HOW
G.M.O. POTATOES WILL KILL US.
>> THE PROCESS ITSELF IS
DANGEROUS.
THEY CREATE A LITTLE PIECE OF
R.N.A., AND PUT IT INTO THE
POTATO SO THAT IT SILENCES SOME
GENES.
IF WE EAT THE POTATO, IT MIGHT
REGULATE OUR OWN GENE
EXPRESSION, CAUTION SERIOUS
PROBLEMS, POSSIBLY DEATH.
>> JESUS.
>> THE TECHNOLOGY ITSELF IT
GENERICALLY UNSAFE.
>> ( BLEEP ) MONSANTO, RIGHT?
>> WELL, NOT IN THE CASE OF THIS
POTATO.
THIS IS SIMPLOT, J.R. SIMPLOT,
THE BIG POTATO PRODUCER.
>> DID YOU SAY SIMPOT?
>> I DID.
>> NO ( BLEEP ). SIMPLOT? YOU
MAY NOT REMEMBER THEM,
BUT I DO.
A FEW YEARS AGO I WENT TO IDAHO
AND UNCOVERED A CONSPIRACY THAT
INVOLVED SIMPLOT, POLUTION, AN
E.P.A. COVER-UP, A TWO-HEADED
FISH AND I WAS ALMOST
ARRESTED TWICE.
IT COULD HAVE RUINED MY CAREER.
SIMPLOT!
I'M NOT DOING IT.
I'M NOT -- I'M NOT DOING SIMPOT.
OKAY.
I'VE DONE IT.
I'VE DONE THAT.
BEEN THERE. ( BLEEP ).
NO! NO! NO YOU GET THE
( BLEEP )
>> THIS IS YOUR ( BLEEP ) SHOW.
>> THIS IS YOU ( BLEEP ) FAULT.
OKAY YOU ( BLEEP ). YOU DIDN'T
TELL ME IT WAS ( BLEEP )
SIMPLOT.
I'M NOT GOING TO DO IT.
BENNETT!
FINE!
( BLEEP ) SIMPLOT.
BUT STRANGELY, ACCORDING TO
CORNELL'S POTATO MOLECULAR
GENETICIST WALTER DE JONG,
SIMPLOT'S DEVIL TATER
IS ACTUALLY AN ANGEL TOT.
>> THE POTATO PRODUCES LESS
ACRYLAMIDE WHEN FRIED.
>> RIGHT.
>> ACRYLAMIDE IS A NEUROTOXIN,
A POSSIBLE CARCINOGEN.
>> WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
SO YOU'RE TELLING ME THE SIMPOT
POTATO CUTS DOWN ON POSSIBLE
CARCINOGENS.
>> YES.
>> BUT WHAT ABOUT LIKE WHEN THE
R.N.A. GETS INTO MY BODY AND
CHANGES MY D.N.A.?
IT'S MOVING ( BLEEP ) AROUND.
>> GENETICALLY MODIFIED CROPS
DON'T ALTER HUMAN D.N.A.
>> WHAT IF THEY DID?
>> THEY DON'T.
OUR BODIES HAVE BEEN SLICING AND
DICING D.N.A. FOR AS LONG AS
WE'VE BEEN IN EXISTENCE.
>> SO THERE'S NO CHANGE TO THE
D.N.A.?
>> THERE'S NO CHANGE TO OUR
D.N.A.
>> SOUNDS LIKE SOMEBODY WHO IS
WORKING FOR SIMPOT.
>> I DON'T WORK FOR SIMPLOT.
>> THEY PAY FOR YOUR
RESEARCH.
>> NO, THEY DON'T FUND MY
RESEARCH IN ANY WAY.
>> THEN YOU GO TO THEIR PARTIES
AND YOU HANG OUT WITH THEM.
>> NO, I DO NOT.
>> OKAY, OKAY, JUST BECAUSE HE'S
NOT ON THE POTATO'S PAYROLL,
DOESN'T MEAN OTHER FRANKEN
VEGGIES WON'T KILL US.
THERE'S ALSO CORN THAT
PRODUCES ITS OWN TOXIC
INSECTICIDE THAT BREAK OPEN
LITTLE HOLES IN HUMAN CELLS AS
WELL.
>> THE BT PROTEIN THAT
YOU'RE REFERING TO DOES NOT
CREATE HOLES IN OUR CELLS.
>> NO, LIKE IT LIKE BURNS
THROUGH THE CELL AND CREATES
A HOLE IN YOUR CELL.
>> WHAT WOULD MAKE A HOLE IN
YOUR CELL?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
NO, NO I HEARD THAT SOMEWHERE.
>> IT'S-- YEAH.
>> SO YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT
THESE POTATOES ARE NOT
DANGEROUS.
>> THE POTATO IS JUST AS SAFE AS
COCONVENTIONALLY DEVELOPED
POTATOES.
>> PO-TAT-O.
>> POTATO.
>> REALLY, IT'S NOT DANGEROUS?
THAT'S NOT DANGEROUS.
>> PLEASE STOP DOING THAT.
>> THAT'S NOT DANGEROUS. THAT'S
NOT DANGEROUS?
PRETTY DANGEROUS TO ME.
TURNS OUT THAT WALTER'S NOT
ALONE.
A RECENT PEW POLL SHOWS THAT 88%
OF SCIENTISTS BELIEVE G.M.O.s
ARE SAFE, WHILE ONLY 37% OF
AMERICANS BELIEVE THEM.
BUT LUCKY FOR US--
>> I'M NOT A SCIENTIST.
I'M NOT A SCIENTIST.
I WORK-- I INTERVIEW SCIENTISTS
AND TRANSLATE SCIENCE INTO
ENGLISH SO THAT EVERYONE CAN
UNDERSTAND.
SO, YEAH, I'VE INTERVIEWED A LOT
OF SCIENTISTS, TOO.
>> SOMETIMES I PURPOSELY PLAY
DUMB SO THAT THEY EXPLAIN IT IN
A WAY THAT MAKES IT
REALLY CLEAR, AND--
>> I DO THE SAME THING.
>> AND I -- YEAH.
>> I KNOW WHAT YOU MEAN.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE ).
>> DAVID SUZUKI, A GENETICIST
AND TV PERSONALITY SAID IF ANY
SCIENTIST TELLS THAT YOU
G.M.O.s ARE SAFE, THEY'RE
EITHER VERY STUPID OR LYING.
>> I SEE, SO SCIENTISTS ARE ALL
STUPID LIARS, WHICH I SUPPOSE IS
WHY NONE OF THE ACTUAL SIMPLOT
POTATO SCIENTISTS WOULD TALK TO
US.
>> NO, THEY'RE WORRIED THAT
THEIR LABS AND FIELDS WILL BE
TARGETED.
>> TARGETED BY WHO?
>> G.M.O. FOES.
>> SO THE ANTI-G.M.O. PEOPLE ARE
THE ASSHOLES
AND SIMPLOT ARE THE GOOD GUYS.
>> UNCHARACTERISTIC, BUT YES.
>> OKAY, OKAY, BUT THESE
AGRA-BUSINESSES HAVE A MONOPOLY
ON OUR ENTIRE FOOD SUPPLY AND
THAT IS A HORRIFYING FACT
THAT EVEN SCIENTISTS
CANNOT ARGUE, RIGHT?
>> ACTUALLY, THE GREATEST
DAMAGE DONE BY THE ANTI-G.M.O.
LOBBY IS THE THE
INCREASED REGULATORY COSTS
THAT ANYONE NOW DEVELOPING A
GENETICALLY MODIFIED CROP
HAS TO GO THROUGH MEANS THAT
ONLY THE BIG COMPANIES WITH
THE DEEPEST POCKETS CAN PLAY AND
IT'S LEADING TO A HAND FULL OF
COMPANIES CONTROLLING SEEDS OF
ALL OF OUR MAJOR CROPS.
>> SO YOU'RE SAYING THE
ANTI-GMO LOBBY IS ACTUALLY
RESULTING IN A MONOPOLY BY
COMPANIES LIKE SIMPLOT AND
MONSTANTO.
>> IT'S AN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE, YES.
>> THAT'S LIKE ( BLEEP ).
SO THERE YOU HAVE IT.
IN THIS STORY IT'S NOT
SCIENTISTS OR AGRO-BUSINESS
MESSING WITH OUR FOOD SUPPLY.
IT'S PEOPLE WHO HAVE CONVINCED
THE WORLD THAT THE SIMPLOT
POTATO WILL TURN THIS INTO THIS.
>> IT'S MR. G.M.O POTATOHEAD.
>> I LOVE YOU G.M.O. POTATOHEAD.
>> I'M GOING TO EAT SOME NOW.
♪ ♪ ♪
( LAUGHTER )